conages n.vallaud belkacem ne fasse pas
preuve d'hypocrisie
il est connu et c'est connu que c'est
une défenseur de la théorie du genre
elle s'est plusieurs fois tu sais que
j'ai fait du jld en existe plusieurs
fois exprimé dessus mais pas pour la
théorie du genre vous êtes vous l'avez
entendu dire je suis pour la théorie du
genre est bien sûr personne ne sait
exactement ce que c'est d'ailleurs moi
nous allons mener un travail équivalent
sur la question de l'orientation
sexuelle sur la question de l'identité
de genre donc ça va être extrêmement
enthousiasmant je tiens énormément au
travail sur l'éducation nationale et les
stéréotypes ça se déconstruit dès le
plus jeune âge et la question de
l'égalité quelle que soit l'orientation
sexuelle ou l'identité de genre je pense
que il faut profiter de
comment dire de cette porte entrouverte
pour y glisser la question aussi de
l'orientation sexuelle et l'identité de
genre d'un jeu quelques petits services